ESL Pro League season 16 came to a close
of the weekend and as per usual it was a
banger power Dynamic shifted records
were broken and a certain Frenchman
might have finally found his destined
Supporting Cast oh and there's some more
N.A copium stuff but we'll get into that
there's a lot to cover so let's Jump
Right In
[Music]
the last few seasons of pro league have
all produced some pretty crazy results
from the Canadian clutch to phase Reigns
Redemption
[Music]
and season 16 was no exception heading
into it there was a lot of questions
surrounding some of the top teams and
how they'd perform would there finally
be some competition or was it just going
to be another phase Navi Grand Final but
I think it's fair to say that nobody saw
this coming things immediately got spicy
in the group stages G2 and vitality
teams that have been struggling as of
lately went undefeated in their groups
and hooksy g2's igl that was previously
getting me deemed into Oblivion might
have finally won the community over who
stole them they're coming through
oh yeah they're trying oh see though
this
is gonna keep going obviously beautiful
defense and Ace to close up the round
with that's gonna get G2 fired up over
in group D we saw liquid Furia and
Cloud9 battle it out for the top spot
and minus some shaky moments liquid made
it out of the group stages and looked
pretty strong doing it however the real
test would be in the playoffs despite
the domination the team showed
throughout the year FaZe and Navi would
both underperform getting knocked out in
the quarterfinals by Cloud9 and G2
respectively this was a pretty big shock
everyone expected at least Faze or Navi
to make a deep run but it just goes to
show how competitive the scene is right
now and this is it Ralph's gonna Round
the Corner into the event the tech nine
and knocked me in there is 16 to 11
Cloud 9 through the semi-finals taking
on liquid massive stuff something to be
proud of that's a great performance Navi
are left in a one on five was simple on
the up he's gonna try desperately to
work his way back toward the site but
the flank is in and it's hooksy to shut
it down fittingly 16-9 it's not the go
on
and two are moving on G2 would go on to
meet Vitality in the semi-finals and as
I've mentioned before these two teams
have been the topic of a lot of
discussions over in the EU they have
both made large and expensive roster
changes that have yet to Bear any real
fruit but with this matchup one team was
going to move on to the Grand finals and
really get a chance to prove themselves
they're gonna have to boost they have to
try and find something here G2 it's all
going to fall apart as soon as hooksies
know to know where both players are the
smokes Vader this is it Yep they're
going for it Bootsy leading the charge
1916 and vitality they find a spot in
the Grand Final on the other side of the
bracket all the hopes and dreams of n a
and Dimitri's mental health rested on
the shoulders of Team Liquid despite
defeating solid teams like fnatic and
mouse they would still have the face a
scary looking Cloud9 C9 were coming off
a win at IEM Dallas a tournament that
liquid didn't even make it out of groups
for but this time liquid look dialed in
and they weren't going to make the same
mistakes twice Shiro's not that looking
that direction either but naps give up
on that why would he go down and make
this a two on three why would he give
them a chance instead he'll play for
trade to join his teammates in the site
and it's over now OC and Nitro will give
liquid the win 16-13 that's twice they
beat Cloud Nine in pro league and with
that liquid made it to their first Grand
finals since 2019. now I am no
Nostradamus but a team Vitality liquid
Grand finals is not what I had on my
bingo card but I was down nonetheless
because if you think about it heading
into this Grand finals both teams had a
lot in common I think it's completely
fair to say that each team hasn't been
reaching their full potential as of late
and despite some roster changes
nothing's made enough of a difference
now that was until they both seemingly
found their missing piece Sphinx in
vitality and yakindar in Team Liquid and
let me just say this all of these
ingredients LED for a pretty crazy best
of five it started with each
convincingly taking their own map pick
but Mirage would head to a wild triple
overtime resulting in Team Liquid taking
the series lead and they have a chance
on this Dupree is Frozen in place he is
scared right now and he's gonna get
spotted out as Elise jumps away a
doubling up and they're all gonna go
down Lake was going to take it with a
clean sweep and triple over time liquid
went on to take a 12-8 lead on overpass
but that's when everything started to
turn sour for Na's last hope this is
well clay more overtimes played and a
Fifth map is coming up Vitality
Victoria's on overpass now I am not
saying that this is entirely the reason
but Nitro and Alicia's performances
started to drop leaving nafikindar and
OC to carry the team that being said
there might not be much you can do when
zybu gets activated it's especially
unfortunate when he's having the literal
series of his career I mean it zaiwu
dropped a record-breaking 143 frags and
ended the tournament with a 1.39 hltv
rating to give some context coldzera
held the previous record with 130 kills
back in 2017. it's like we somehow
forget how much of a demon this
kid is they haven't spotted time he's
gonna have two guns and two Targets
he'll find both of those oh my God it's
that third one as he spins around if he
goes down here with this gun they're
gonna not have any to work with in the
next round but he starts this off very
well very very well indeed okay two
kills through the smoke you're right no
kick but he's spotted out nav he's got
tons of time on this what is I were
doing but it is let's see what he's
gonna do he's real close they don't know
about it it's the one kill goes for a
second one right around the corner he's
hunting him down he'll find him that is
a miraculous clutch suffice to say Team
Liquid would slightly choke the rest of
the series and vitality would take the
victory much to the Chagrin of n a and
of course Dimitri what a clutch this
would be for the elite Elise he's got an
AK now to work with that'll boost his
chances ever so slightly but they are
going to be so disciplined they are not
gonna Peak unless it's in Tandem and
they go
years a new record and vitality lives up
to their name with perseverance in a
very long seven-hour plus series as
tough as the loss was for us across the
Atlantic it was nice to see zaiwu
finally find some success again also
Dupree became the first CS GoPro to
surpass two million dollars in
tournament earnings which is pretty damn
impressive and despite the na copium
that's being siphoned into my room as we
speak liquid looked pretty damn good in
fact the whole tournament was awesome a
lot of teams looked more competitive
than usual and leading to the Rio rmrs
this could spell for the most insane
major ever as per CS go usual we'll just
have the patiently wait and see although
it's not too many sleeps away now so for
any other CS go news that comes in the
future keep it locked here because we're
going to keep you guys up to date
oh yeah I'm definitely going to do that
I'm definitely going to watch League of
Legends worlds
blink twice if you're against your will
is it during Canadian Thanksgiving these
are the two options it's avoid your
family and watch League of Legends or be
with your family